[Music]
tonight that's right we're talking about
the nocturnal flying mammals bats
besides being a source of Halloween
inspiration that disguise of a certain
wealthy vigilante and one of nature's
most accomplished pest control workers
bats have gotten a bad rap outbreaks and
pandemics have resulted in bats making
headlines due to their ability to spread
viruses like SARS and MERS this has made
them an easy target for those who wish
to take bats out of the picture so what
if like a bunch of villagers mobbing
together to take on a vampire we decided
to exterminate our planets bat
population what would a world without
bats be like would it be better for way
worse this is what if and here's what
would happen if all the bats disappeared
bats have had a questionable reputation
at best even before their links to
pandemics some people have even
suggested that we kill all the bats to
protect our health but before you get
your pitchforks and torches ready let's
allow them to plead their case bats are
a diverse bunch with over 1,400 species
they come in all shapes and sizes
ranging from the dime-sized bumblebee
bat to the black flying fox which has a
wingspan of up to 1.8 metres Oh black
flying fox with your 1.8 meter wingspan
please be gentle with me while some bats
are carnivorous most eat insects and
they are more than earning their keep
it's estimated that 99% of crop pests
are controlled to some extent by bats
studies suggest that insect eating bats
provide a service to u.s. agriculture
that is worth at least 3.7 billion
dollars each year and could be as much
as fifty three billion dollars and that
doesn't include the value of everything
bats do like controlling insects that
affect the lumber industry a single
colony of 150 brown bats in Indiana can
eat around 1.3 million insects each year
these bad boys who are little brown bats
can eat 4 to 8 grams of insects a night
during their active season so what does
all this mean well let's say pests are
decimating the crops on your farm if you
decided to get rid of our nocturnal
comrades it would cause an estimated 74
dollars of damage per acre to your crops
in the US so if we didn't have any bats
the damage to 378 million acres of
farmland could cost us about 273 billion
dollars and that's just the money side
of losing bats bats eat insects with
mosquitos being a particularly favorite
dish so if we killed all the bats we
would see a lot more mosquitoes and also
arise in the diseases we get from them
malaria dengue fever and other health
problems would be more common and we
would need more healthcare resources to
deal with them this may lead to a
decrease in tourism in some areas
because of the higher chances of getting
malaria or dengue fever and on top of an
almost biblical plague of insects you
would start to see food shortages bats
pull double duty by acting as important
pollinators and seed spreaders
the agave plant relies solely on bats
for pollination in deserts bats
pollinate cactus plants without bats
cacti may slowly disappear and since
cacti store water this would lead to
water shortages and drier ecosystems the
rainforests would struggle to regrow
without bats spreading seeds this could
lead to the loss of habitat for other
animals and the slow decrease of
rainforest trees other forests around
the world would start to disappear too
without these important animals fruits
would be damaged and without bats to
pollinate them fruits may even disappear
from grocery stores think about it a
world with no bananas or avocados I
don't want to live in that world so the
bottom line is we need bats to continue
the valiant work they're doing in fact
we may even be able to learn from them
bats have a tolerance to viruses that
surpasses all other mammals why are they
able to carry so many different diseases
and not have to take a single sick day
well that question has been perplexing
scientists for a very long time while it
may seem like bats are more dangerous
than they are helpful they are extremely
important for our ecosystems when we're
fast asleep they're out there fighting
the good fight fly on bats fly on nature
is full of natural pest controllers and
without them we'd be in serious trouble
we'd have to take on the fight against
insects like mosquitoes by ourselves now
what if we managed to kill all the
mosquitoes in the world well that's a
story for another what if
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]